Florida lawmakers are taking the first
steps toward raising the age limit to
buy the kind of rifle used to kill 17
people at Marjory Stoneman Douglas High
School President Trump did not mention
that proposal yesterday when he met with
a group of governor's including
Florida's Rick Scott the president has
encouraged the idea putting him on a
collision course with the National Rifle
Association but he told the governor's
at some times elected officials have to
fight the NRA president has also talked
with Republican congressional leaders
who are less interested in a gun control
fight major Garrett is at the White
House where mr. Trump also added to
criticism of the police response to the
Florida shooting good morning major good
morning president Trump wants to move on
at least some gun restrictions but the
republican-led Congress fearful of
antagonizing its political base isn't
budging in part because it sees the
president's low approval ratings and
wonders if he can provide any practical
political cover meanwhile in a
conversation here yesterday with about
40 governors the president's idea of
arming school personnel with concealed
weapons met pockets of resistance they
weren't exactly Medal of Honor winners
President Trump
lashed out at Broward County sheriff's
deputies who have been accused of
responding too slowly at the school
during the shooting the way they
performed was frankly disgusting mr.
Trump said he would have gone in I
really believed I'd run into even if I
didn't have a weapon the president told
the gathering of Governors that NRA
executives assured him during a lunch
over the weekend that they quote want to
do something don't worry about the NRA
they're on our side
Senate Minority Leader Chuck Schumer
said the NRA cannot be trusted my
Republican friends face a simple choice
do something real on guns or please
the NRA doing both is impossible the
president is pushing a controversial NRA
supported proposal arming school
personnel to deter or repeal potential
killers they have to know they walk in
they're going to probably end up dead
but Washington governor jay Inslee a
Democrat said teachers and members of
law enforcement from his state oppose
the idea that educators should educate
and they should not be forced
this responsibility of packing heat in
first grade classes which we need a
little less tweeting here a little more
listening and let's just take that off
the table and move forward in a rare
public speech First Lady Melania Trump
praised the students who have taken to
the streets to call for gun restrictions
many of which the president has opposed
they're our future and they deserve a
voice Republican leaders in Congress
foresee no gun action this week and the
only bill at least right now that
appears to have a chance is an NRA
backed initiative that would incentivize
use of the existing background check
system that bill called fix Nick's would
not expand background checks to internet
or gun show sales Nora important point
there major thank you so much